if we are here because of our teachers
and I am here because of build all the
real heroes are the people that that
introduced theater to children the more
we can celebrate that people that are on
the front lines with children that see
that and still that and then the the
better our society is I think arts
education was necessary because we we've
seen it and we know that a person was a
with an ability to gain a perspective
outside of their current circumstance is
a person that changes the world we
wouldn't be able to exist without arts
education and we wouldn't be able to
operate as a society without the art
what the arch does whether you go into
theatre film or TV or whatever what we
have is imagination and I'd like to
thank my students who have been an
inspiration over the years to me
[Music]
you